hello everyone its Perry back here with
an exclusive Collider interview that I
am so so excited for right now I am
talking to Harry from too hot to handle
how you doing round I'm good I'm just
like grinning from ear to ear because
this show is exactly what I needed in my
life right now for anybody watching
we're gonna go full spoilers and too hot
to handle right now so if you haven't
watched it go check it out on Netflix
all eight episodes are up and running
no time to waste get on it and then come
back to this conversation because my
first question for you I'm just I'm
going for it I'm just going for the one
that everyone wants the answer to are
you and Francesca still together we are
we actually had a bit of a break in
between after the show so we were
together for a couple months and then I
moved to LA and then the age-old tale of
just getting drunk and texting your ex
kinda came up and then next thing you
know she's here way better than we were
before which is amazing that makes me so
incredibly happy so I guess the the end
result here is that this this experiment
worked for you yeah it's crazy
that's incredible yes so have you seen
all eight episodes of the show yourself
now I haven't seen anything at this
point my god its failure and I've
watched that about 400 times there's a
lot more to discover I can promise you
that let's go beat by beat a little here
because I have a bunch of burning
questions first I want to know that
first kiss that the two of you were
fined for so on the show we never seen
you admit that maybe you initiated it
you guys ever talk about it off camera
or maybe after the show wrapped up that
was the first thing I said to her I was
like look I'm gonna be the first to
admit I'm a bit of a dick and in that
moment they kind of the bad side of me
kind of took over and yeah I apologize
as I said like I know it's gonna come
out
and the rest of the cast is gonna be
kind of confused she's just like yeah I
don't know why I don't know why you did
that and then I don't know why did it
well yeah let's focus on the positives
can you blame it at all I'm just I don't
know that like the cameras and that
whole situation because I imagine that
kind of takes you out of reality to to a
tiny degree at least I think with these
situations the only time that you think
about the cameras and everything that's
going on around you is like the first
like hour of being there and in their
retreat so as soon as like you're there
and then you're like 20 these people and
there's just so much like stuff going on
in front of you you completely forget
about the cameras and it's just like
yeah it's it's crazy
all right I'm jumping from one big
moment for you to another so the second
time you guys go in that private suite
together you do know 100% that the two
you guys were not going to break the
rules or was there any legitimate back
and forth while you were in there about
whether or not to break it so I'm not
sure if if the they put in the rest of
the cast like they weren't happy about
us getting the chance to go into there
like angry at us and Francesca had it
come with drinks she was like you know
what
stuff it let's just spend the rest of
money let's have a great night to
ourselves and I was like what are you
doing no let's be wholesome and then
yeah like we discussed like we like this
door it was there I'm not gonna lie like
I was like you know I like everyone's
angry let's be spiteful but then you
know we've thought about the reason why
we're doing this and the reason why
we've got so far is because we're trying
to get deeper connections and we're
trying to not upset everyone else and
yeah so that was I think that was one of
my favorite surprises from the entire
season of the show I was just I was so
happy for you guys yeah it was kinda
crazy who actually said you the it there
for like 24 hours video is that it was
so like intense did not even get
anywhere near each other like I've never
but I've never been like so like
cautious of where someone is in the room
I'm like oh I'm gonna go to the toilet
like so you
you make sure you were there because I'm
gonna brush posture on this I can't
believe you guys were in there for 24
hours doing that I just assumed it was a
kind of like an evening to mid mid day
the next day kind of sit around I wish
it was as well like suspense and then we
came back and everyone had their doubts
this pen is very successful there so
wait what were you guys doing the entire
time so I showed Francesca
how well I swim in the waters going
everywhere and I was just freaking out
that you're a wreck in the bathroom I
was I was just like you know bit of
razzle-dazzle bells let's go I like it I
don't know what else to do
we played card games and there was like
a whole bunch like sex toys and stuff
like that so I got the handcuffs
handcuffed myself to a chair I'm not
gonna go anyway knee you come on and
then she was like now gotcha yeah we
just we honestly just made it up and had
fun and it was it was kind of good
because it was a bit of a break from all
their like heavy stuff that was going on
in the show it was really there's such a
great way to wrap up for season two I
just love that that was all kind of
towards the end of the thing so this is
a little bit of a heavier question and I
don't want to throw her under the bus
but if Haley had stayed on for the full
season do you think that things would
have panned out with you and Francesca
as well because Haley definitely enjoyed
kind of like the puppeteering behind the
scenes and manipulating the situation
yes for sure I honestly don't think me
and Francesca would have kicked off as
well as we did I think purely because
like Haley wasn't taking the whole
retreat serious and I think she was kind
of there to just have fun and extend the
pot and you know do what she does so I
genuine anything like if she stayed
Francesca would have been torn I would
have been like you know like stare at a
tea and just keep stirring the pot or do
I just give this a go so yeah I honestly
think that it would have been a
completely different show if Eddie
stayed I actually have a good follow up
question for your phone blowing up right
now because you know it's it's bound to
happen
so as we're recording this interview
right now the show hasn't aired on
Netflix but it's going to very very soon
and at the very beginning of the season
you mentioned that you like to slide
into celebrity DMS you don't hear back
from anyone but I've got a feeling that
after this show you might have a better
chance so who is the first celebrity
you're gonna DM when this airs oh I
can't I I would have to be a guy like me
okay sameen face yes it actually had
this conversation yesterday thank you
she's because she I was like you know it
like it's gonna be quite intense you're
gonna have like a lot of attention and a
lot of male attention and I trust you
like I trust that you're not gonna
respond to anyone and they say it's
completely harmless
she said yeah amazing / like but she's
like I don't know if I trust you that
there's gonna be these Instagram models
in at the end because I asked I'm like
who is my full pots like tell me can I
please like have a whole pot like Julie
but I only brought a just someone and
she's like nah no that I'm like you can
be there it's not like it's gonna be bad
but she's like nothing you even think
about that game over so anyone against
my games you're probably gonna not be
answered oh how the tables have turned
one of the things that I'm busy
preparing for it's her to write a piece
about is just like the biggest holy [ __ ]
moments of the show but it's one thing
from a viewer perspective and it's
cooked
whoa I think a tree just go outside
so my holy [ __ ] moments are probably
very different from yours having
physically been there on set for the
filming so what was the moment of all of
the ones on this season of the show that
made you go like I can't believe I'm
experiencing this right now you know
honestly I think the the rules being
dropped is probably my biggest like I
don't know you can tell like I went
white like I lost I felt sick I thought
that was the end of the world like I
legitimately was like you couldn't have
given me worse and news right now but I
think my biggest like holy [ __ ] moment
the hot water challenge and like just
seeing the kind of like I'm like
unfolding the kind of the pages of some
of the guys and getting a little bit
more about them and like there's people
like in so much way worse
you know upbringing and stuff like that
and it just kind of made me maybe a
little bit more humble and like kind of
bring them back down to earth about you
know stuff that was going on I think
like that was probably the biggest the
biggest moment for me I know you
probably won like okay like a massive
moment bossing in all honestly like
that's not thinking I can think of that
made me like take a step back and
reevaluate everything well that's part
of the reason why I really appreciated
the show in the end like it's it's fun
and it's crazy but those those moments
are what really showed that the change
is happening I appreciate it stuff like
that yeah magic touch with a lot of the
guys because you've got you've got a
romantic relationship right now but it
seems like you guys really built up some
real friendships there yeah no I'm I'm
friends with pretty much all the guys
like we're all pretty close but you know
as there was like moments in the show
and they're like hey look you're not
hanging out with us you know trying to
be here to be our friend and I was like
guys like I'm not here like I'm trying
to find love like come on like let me
pursue this with Francesca so I think my
relationships on this road with the lads
wasn't as strong as it could have been
but right now I mean most of that's a
pretty ace pretty maybe I like hearing
that as well so we see a lot of what
goes on while you were in the retreat
but I'm sure there's some stuff that
happened off camera is there anything
that went on that we're not gonna get to
see that's just I don't know a really
powerful memory for you that you wish
you could share I think I'm not sure
about the final the like the final day
that we were filming it was probably the
most oh I don't even said his name as
well it was the most overwhelmed I've
ever felt about the whole situation I'm
not I don't think this will probably be
hit but I mean Francesca laying on the
lawn like we had a little mattress and
just watching all the iguanas in the
trees
I was just naming them like we were
creating stories for them and then I
just started crying like I was just
and she's like what's wrong and I was
like it's not like it's sad like I just
feel like so fulfilled from this whole
experience and the fact that I got you
out of this and I my whole mentality
changed and like I feel like I'm a
completely different person is something
I never could have imagined or you know
knew that would have been something that
I needed and I was just just crying and
she's like it's okay I was like no it's
the best it is the absolute best and
like I remember I was just like getting
tingly goosebumps I've never felt like
that before I think I was just the fact
that I'm with Francesca my heart was
literally about to explode it was just
full of love and yeah after all that
what was the first thing you did when
you got home I mean was there like a
homesickness for the group is there
anything that like kind of didn't feel
the same to you anymore I went on book
flights straight to Vancouver I like I
honestly because it was crazy because as
soon as we want to like once we started
we would just giving each other 110% as
soon as like someone like went away from
an interview or like the confession room
we get like I'd get like a little bit of
like homesickness I'm like where's she
going like it's been ten minutes I come
back like we're both glued to each other
the whole time and I'm like do I
seriously have to mingle or talk to
anyone else like this is a joke which is
probably super toxic trait that we had
at the time but yeah the first thing I
did was go kiss you because um yeah I
was just like man they do fit to it and
I'm so happy for you guys
this is like seriously the best answer
you could have given me to that first
question and then beyond so you make all
these first impressions when you first
meet everybody else who would you say is
the contestant that proved you wrong the
most where your first impression was
nothing like who they turned out to be I
think sure Ron I think he really
actually well I think Francesca like
completely changed as well but I've
spoken enough about her she gets a
little lonely right now
I think sure on this show like he
he went in and I never liked talking to
him at the start compared to like his
mindset at the end it was just like yeah
it was it was amazing it was
overwhelming I was really cool to see so
my last question for you right now
having had such a great experience on
this and clearly making the most of the
purpose of the show what advice would
you give to somebody else who maybe is
about to whether it's too hot to the
handle season 2 or any other kind of
dating reality show what advice would
you give to someone jumping into a thing
like that my mind by socks I'm always
like don't think about anything just go
like just follow your heart just go
crazy and do what you feel is gonna be
best and most beneficial but also
understand that you're probably like
like just try not to hurt other people
my biggest thing is like when I'm in the
well I actually I've got like two brain
cells like 24/7 so I usually don't think
about stuff and it always gets me in
trouble so I think this situation helped
me like understand that like I will
upset other people but I think in any
reality show or dating shows don't over
overthink anything because you've got
nothing else to do so we're gonna do is
overthink so you may as well just give
it everything you got and follow your
heart and try and find that special
person clearly it worked for you it's
gonna hit home with someone else out
there I promise you that Harry thank you
so much and congratulations seriously on
having had such a great experience
because this is a blast watching you
guys you seem so happy now and I'm happy
for you alright guys thank you so much
for watching this interview weigh in
with your thoughts in the comment
section below and we'll see you soon
with more Collider exclusives